President Trump is promising major
overhaul of America's infrastructure but
his proposed trillion dollars might not
be enough in our new series rebuilding
America we will look at several projects
and the options to pay for them
they include public-private partnerships
which are widely expected to play a big
role in mr. Trump's plan and those
partnership fewer taxpayer dollars are
needed because private industry picks up
some of the cost Kris Van Cleave is in
Vienna Virginia just outside Washington
along interstate 495 to show how these
projects can work Chris good morning
good morning Virginia is a big believer
in public-private partnerships and
points to successes like the Express
Lanes here along the Beltway where a
driver can choose to pay a toll to get
around congestion they say it's been a
big success but those successes have
come with some costly mistakes every
time you get into your car it's like
catching chain coadley Linda dyers daily
commute is taking a toll whenever she
leaves home she's paying to use tunnels
that used to be free now she's thinking
about moving elsewhere we're spending
$1200 a year in tolls yeah and my
biggest concern is it going to affect
how easy it is for me to sell my house
Virginia agreed to a 58 year deal with a
private company to modernize and expand
the tunnels linking Portsmouth and
Norfolk to military towns separated by
the Elizabeth River the tolls to cross
can run a driver 525 each way do you
just get mad do you see a difference in
people coming to town yes I do Tony
Goodwin is the president of the old town
Portsmouth Business Association and is a
trump voter the tolls have basically
come a stigma to the population of
Hampton Roads between Norfolk and
Portsmouth mainly because of the fact
that it's almost putting up a wall
between two cities inside of a one
community many in this working-class
community couldn't afford their commute
forcing the state to pony up nearly
three hundred million extra dollars to
buy down the tolls meaning that we could
have done that project ourselves so that
project just was a loser great
transportation project that needed to be
done the infrastructure
solutely was needed the way we financed
it was not such a great deal for the
Commonwealth of Virginia our rellenas
Virginia Secretary of Transportation
he's a Republican in a Democratic
administration and supports
public/private partnerships their
business deals thought to be at the
center of President Donald Trump's 1
trillion dollar infrastructure plan
where does a private public partnership
work heavily urbanized areas where
there's the ability of congestion where
people are willing to pay a price to get
out of that that's what's happening in
Northern Virginia where express lanes
have been added to unclog several
freeways drivers pay a toll to avoid
traffic while helping ease congestion in
the Freeland we have found here on 95
that we've freed up 20% more capacity in
those lanes about people opting in to
the HOT lanes to work public-private
partnerships must be able to show a
steady profit which many infrastructure
projects simply won't and 15 states
currently do not allow them which could
limit the impact of President Trump's
plan how big of a burden is the toll you
don't have a choice you can't avoid it I
can't avoid it is this tunnel project a
cautionary tale to the Trump
administration yes I think that what's
most important is they need to simply
look very closely at how the project is
being funded and at the end of the day
what are the taxpayers going to be
responsible for under the arrangement
that they make with these public-private
partnerships and after the tunnel
project Virginia changed the way they
approach public-private partnerships the
first the state must show that the
private industry can deliver it at a
lower cost of taxpayers otherwise the
state will do it itself now there is
room to expand p3s or public-private
partnerships in the u.s. they make up
only about one percent of infrastructure
projects here in Europe it's closer to
ten percent gaile all right thank you
Chris